you'll see the muscles were hooking it
down the hill first okay ah good morning
it is a bright Saturday morning and what
are we doing today we're doing our part
for the environment today and are going
to go plant some trees but first
breakfast Evans going in to get some
breakfast from from where Timmy's what
do you have to say Hayden um no I
management for today not the first
person and not the second person hmm
it's not the third it might be before it
is the fourth one here's comes daddy
you ready mr. yes you're going to plant
the big tree tree plaintain this way
putting it down the hill first
okay ah Haven got special gloves Wow
planting gloves you want to help you
kick does it have to match there you go
huh good okay right here give it up cool
we're going to learn how to plant trees
you'll see the muscles were
it surely it's the birthday girl haha
happy birthday it's a good day man I
know no well yeah we went to the
training no we've never done it you went
to the training and that's it Hayden's
ready to go Corbin's attacking the pile
of dirt we're going to try with this
tree what are we going to name this tree
the daddy tree this is a American elder
Teemo treat American elder ok let's dig
a hole
you
get the place here we got mulch bucket
number one ready you ready mr. let's see
this nope push push push it push it
really looks good can we get an official
inspection on our tree this is it Oh
wonderful what do you think it looks
like you've had a good level all right
good yep and it's got a nice jonat
around it so well Don be passed all
right well good we pass ok ok now Nina's
turn doing our part for the environment
plenty some trees thank you to Christian
so I'm happy working on power but little
things add up ok but hey we're promoting
it now you know right other people learn
about it yeah it's go plant the tree and
check out have to work or calm
this is the knee none hate entry what's
it called well I'll go in rows put the
wizard tree all right done
trees everywhere
okay so we had a fun day planting trees
we did our good for the environment
today so guys watching get out there do
something nice to help the planet master
Bruce we got the broomstick enjoy your
friends and family and believe we'll see
you soon